well soft is 14 inches soft alright it's
14 inches aw
[Music]
to another episode of wfe with just me
and Craig today sadly we were hoping for
Coke I guess we'll plug for him house in
okay
he might have passed out cousin working
his butt off but coke is gonna be
fighting see fight UFC on the 27th of
this month January 27 so coming up real
soon
actually let me just go to his page
because I just want to want to see if
he's got the info I don't guess it's
gonna be on like Fox Sports 1 again
right you think I have no idea
alright give me two seconds who is he
fighting I'm gonna give you all the
number me okay give me 20 seconds here
okay so coke is gonna be fighting North
Carolina January 27 for Rufus Sport UFC
but of the year it's a Bobby green
versus erich koch Bobby green so look
for coke January 27th support our boy
he's gonna be in North Carolina for UFC
fighting Bobby green alright coke that's
our shout out to coke oh yeah hopefully
he might call in still but he might be
passed out from working out ok we're um
this episode's I mean this episode we're
gonna answer some questions of via
Instagram we got a couple questions yes
cuz you know it's late late notice but
so the first one comes from a Shang two
low TLO do you guys play any PC games no
ok I don't even have a PC my PC my
desktop is dying but before it died I
did play papers please which was cool
and I played gone home so gone home was
a good game ok alright and then so so
those are the two games I played I wish
I had my PC was up today oh hey here we
go
plugging them in Eric pocus here hey
buddy
egg I'm gonna plug you in can you talk
for a minute
alright can are you able to get them
hey Koki coke yeah hey we're just
plugging your fight man so uh it's a
little staticky okay so we just want to
see how you're doing and did you want to
plug plug anything I just want to thank
all my homies the worst fire team ever
Craig Stevie we be Eric Griffin and
Frank having a blast just even through
the fight camp man you guys don't you
don't know how much you know it passes
and kills time playing video games with
my friends you guys are like a second
family to me so I just want to make a
shout out to wfe alright everybody that
ever everybody that watches the podcast
and may just make sure to tune in to see
me you know fight the 27th this month
next weekend taking on Bobby green you
can watch it live on Fox I'm gonna go
gonna go straight gunslinger on this mob
yeah so you've been how long you been
training for this fight Oh Steve I've
been training so damn long are you still
drinking that muscle milk the muscle
milk yeah yeah I don't I don't do muscle
milk I do I've been doing carnivore
which is my favorite type of protein
okay it's a beef I slip but but no man
waits good everything's good I'm in
shape I'm strong probably the strongest
I've ever been until at 55 55 oh yeah 55
all day but I've kept more lean muscle
and I got a little more mass I'm hitting
like a truck I'm I'm looking for a bonus
man okay this is a real important fight
brother I mean um we're all rooting for
you oh you know every fights important I
think yeah mekt every single fight is
the most important fight of my life but
you know I know you guys got my back and
oh yeah you know all our viewers got my
back so I just want to wrap it
we definitely got your back man we're
super excited
I can just play them on the right up to
the mic all right here are you still
there yeah yeah that's better okay so
anyway we just wanted to give a shout
out brother we're super excited for your
fight we miss you here in LA so
hopefully when you're done we can come
out here and we'll do some more WFP and
hang out
nothing nothing sounds better than
coming out doing more wfv I wanted to I
want to give you update on what I'm I
created a hunter class so my night
stalkers uh my night stalkers a 3:30 now
and she's getting up there yeah so I'm
trying to practice with the smoke yeah
it is this weekend I'm still training
but not as hard so I'm gonna be on quite
a bit are you gonna be on tonight okay
cuz okay because I have a Lani's going
back home so I'll have time to play all
night if you think so if you want to do
I have a hunter so we got like me
Craigan you and we could just throw
Pikachu in there or something
it's been a pretty lonely podcast me
Craig that showed up in yes didn't show
up so so that's the way it's been but we
had a good interview with our buddy and
everything but a man I'm glad you got on
we were getting a little worried because
I want to make sure we plugged you and
you know we talked hey so since you're
here we got a couple questions from the
internet if you don't want to answer
them with us real quick yeah okay so one
of them was do you guys play PC games me
and Steve already answered no I said no
I don't just you know the biggest thing
is this accessibility I used to when I
was younger needs to play a lot of stuff
like boulders gate and Neverwinter
Nights and [ __ ] like that like RPG type
games but dude I haven't played a game
on PC and forever probably the last game
I played
PC which wasn't for that long was right
when Starcraft 2 came out no no PC here
all right all right cool all right so
the next one is what is your favorite
thing about gaming Steve you can go
first
um I think the number one thing for me
is just it's an escape yeah you could
just veg out and you're doing something
fun and it relaxes me
well not not so much the PvP aspect but
the PV last night I was playing
competitive coke and I don't know what
it is about that mode but man at the end
of the game it was 1v4 I was all by
myself versus a team of four dude dude I
got left in the dirt dude they should be
yeah cuz that was not cool on top of
that they all teabag me Steve Steve is
so angry yes as if me like playing up
here yeah I wish they would have I would
have at least I would have gotten
something out of it I know I know I'm
trying to learn the nightstalker too
brother
you know what I mean so I was gonna say
my favorite things excited from escapism
which I agree with is I like stories on
some of the games but the other big one
is being social we will play my friends
and you know do stuff that you can't
always do when you're busier think about
it like we got a strong you know brother
brother ship that we have you know you
guys are my homies I talk to you guys a
lot more than my own family so yeah it's
crazy that technology we don't live
close you know it's still like we
[ __ ] see each other every day
it wasn't even like weird or nothing it
was like John what's up man you know I
can you know just like any other [ __ ]
day Oh crazy the way mm-hmm yeah ya know
for sure it's not really yeah I totally
agree with that yeah you guys are made a
lot of good connects not just with us to
other or outside group - oh yeah for
sure
arrow and Peaks and everybody all right
another question from Sarge scummy is
also what are your current favorite
games and I'm guessing aside from
destiny obviously I like battlefront I
mean I can't live in battlefronts fine
like battlefront I can't there's just
nothing that you're a dusting you guys
there's nothing right now but just even
interesting you know what I am
interested for though to kinda check out
is what's not about I showed you that
trailer it's like the sci-fi EA game
you're lying down I'm not big on this is
why I don't like it because one I like
to play to win and when you're playing
with that many people and you very
rarely win it's it's kind of like a
waste of time to me so when I watch
people play and it takes [ __ ] 35 to
40 minutes to even find somebody and
engage in action it's just i'm i a TD
will not allow me to play [ __ ] like that
you know so I'm not saying I've even
told Craig you know it's a good idea I
understand why people like it just for
me like you know even in destiny you
guys know I run and gun I don't like to
[ __ ] wait scope corners you know but
you said you know and you would try some
just to trial with this I said I would
try it but you know I played for tonight
I know what to expect from it I watched
you guys play so I know I know I know
what it is it's not it's literally the
same thing it's clunky ugh
I'll say that about it's a clunky game
because I've heard everybody PC it's
awesome everything's good counsel I've
you know I've heard nothing but it's
laggy you know I'm down to try it if
people want to see it's just play about
to try it but uh other than that there's
no well I'll tell you because I'm a nerd
gamer I like the new Assassin's Creed
yeah that's good I played with played on
Bob's console I definitely like the new
assassin's creed that was a lot of fun
and you know it was it's a good story
and like I like sometimes just just
vegging out and playing good story I
started getting to Wolfenstein 2 or
whatever it's called and that's that's
also pretty awesome I like the story so
far but I haven't really gotten back
into a first-person shooter
first-person shooter that's like in
Germany killing the Nazis I always like
Nazis so you know that's that deal but
those are my two I think we got just a
couple more questions I think the last
question is okay I think we answered
those three so we have one last question
from Johnny virus Chun and sadly not
everybody's here to answer it but his
question is who has the biggest dick I
would say I would say me soft is 14
inches soft
that's like definitely like a third leg
for you yeah yeah alright well we'll
just go with Steve on that one then no
come on
mine's the smallest everybody knows it
everybody I don't know it I mean it's
okay I'm not no I mean I don't know I
haven't seen you know it's we haven't
done like a circle jerk or showering but
you look at me you know
that's the real who's that why would
this guy want to know I don't know but
I'm here that was the first question I
was asked and that was kind of the funny
it says Johnny virus Chung Chung I mean
I would definitely say you know I can't
speak for everybody else nobody else is
here so okay let's just skip that I'm
just gonna go Steve we'll just well
anyway but if you have any more
questions let us know we'll try to
answer them next forum that's it for now
well because we kind of came in late
with the question thing but I wanted
more questions no because we kind of
came in late that kind of did it
yesterday so there was a lot of time to
really build on that but I appreciate
the question tuning in okay anyway so
again guys cokes fighting January 27th
uh-huh it's Fox one's gonna be a Fox Fox
Sports 1 line what time well I had more
specifics later yeah we'll put it up but
guys check it out look for a coke
fighting we support you brother and
hopefully we'll see you soon yeah
all right get some rest man we'll talk
to you soon okay later all right all
right guys well there we are that's that
concludes that's wfe that's wfe or just
me and Craig today and some day Steve
will be happy just hanging out with me
but you know we'll get hung out with you
for two decades for seven decades anyway
well thank you guys for tuning in that's
wfe and yeah we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]